what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe that you've got some insane
potential inside you that I want to see
burst out into the world to have a big
impact for you your family your
community and everybody around you so to
help you on your journey today I'm going
to talk about seven ways to start a
part-time business so I don't believe
that you have to quit your job and go
all-in on your business especially at
the beginning I'm a big fan of starting
part-time buildings helping up on the
side and then it's a searchable momentum
you can shift more focus towards it but
the key part is starting and actually
doing something about it so today I'm
gonna share with you my seven tips on
how to get your part-time business
started tip number one is schedule
entrepreneur time you need to schedule
it into your calendar you need to put a
barrier around your calendar so that at
least 30 to 60 minutes every single day
is spent building your company that
doesn't sound like a lot of time and in
the grand scheme of things it's not like
you're not spending 5 6 7 8 10 14 hours
a day but what often happens to a lot of
entrepreneurs when they're first getting
started is that they don't allow for
momentum to build up you need to put in
daily work even as little as 30 to 60
minutes every single day to allow for
that momentum to keep going we all have
so many things happen in our life
especially if you have a full time job
working for somebody else you got the
job you got family you know spouse kids
whatever other responsibilities that you
might have you got to deal with that and
those are real there are school or
whatever whatever problems you have
whatever else is picking demands on your
time right most people aren't just
sitting at home all day and saying oh
I've got all this free time what do I do
right there's a lot of demands for your
time from other equipment that you've
made and for other people who want a
piece of you
right it's really hard to stay
consistent in carving out time for
yourself to build your business and this
is where a lot of people will fall down
they have a great idea for a new
business they have great intention to
want to do it they want to you know have
a big impact and the doing it for the
right reasons
they just don't spend the time doing it
and so the key is you need to carve out
some time whatever makes them
cents for your calendar if it's in the
morning if it's over lunch it was in the
evening or lead eating or whatever it is
carve out that time that is your
entrepreneur time nothing touches that
timeless it's a massive emergency and
every single day you are making some
progress
- what's achieving your entrepreneurial
dreams once a week is not going to be
enough we need 30 to 60 minutes every
single day step number two is
determining what kind of business you
want to start you know you have to have
an idea you got to have a plan you got
to know what kind of company you want to
build a service based business is a
great place to start because it's only
your time you don't need to tinker and
tool away and create a product and you
never know if you're getting feedback
from the customer it's gonna work out or
not but starting with what is the thing
that makes you excited what is your big
idea what are you passionate about and
how can you combine that with something
that can help others so if you just are
excited by something and you're really
passionate about it but nobody cares
about it you have a hobby that's not
something that you're gonna ever make
money off of but it might fulfil you you
might love painting Smurfs but if nobody
wants to buy that Smurfs then you just
have a hobby for yourself if you're only
chasing the opportunities like here's
where people are making a lot of money
you open up ink magazine and it's the
hottest 50 companies to start next year
if that's all you're doing but you don't
have a passion for it you're gonna lose
because the people who love those
businesses will crush you
you know if YouTube is a hot business to
start the people who love doing YouTube
will crush you if you're only doing it
because you think it's a hot opportunity
so you need to have both you've got to
find the thing that you love doing where
there's also an interest from people who
will care about it once you find that
those are the seeds of starting the
great business so you've got to figure
out what kind of company you're going to
start
[Music]
step number three is honestly assess
your skills you got to figure out am I
good enough to do this thing yet this
business that I want to start this
service I want to provide this product I
want to create can I actually make
something that is gonna be good enough
for the market can I make something that
people will pay me for so you may want
to go off and create this kind of
business but if you don't have the
skills to do it yet then you need to
learn the skills it's not that it's not
possible you just need to improve your
skills to be able to get to that point
when I started working with Lilly as
part of her unlocking Lilly series right
I invested in Lilly I'm mentoring and
training her to become a speaker it's
her lifelong goal to be a speaker she
wasn't a great speaker at the start
right is there a market yes you know can
you get paid to to have that as a
business yes can we build a
million-dollar business off of that 100%
but not yet because you suck at speaking
right that's okay now we need to work on
that skill set we have to build it up so
at the beginning all of her speeches
were free right she's speaking at local
events she's speaking at a TEDx talk she
drove to different states to practice
her speaking gigs when people gave her
opportunities and she's not charging yet
for speaking because she needs to get
better she needs to improve she needs to
put in the work put in the hours
hone her skills so that you can start
getting paid to speak and so it's
honestly assessing where you're at with
your skill set is what you're doing
valuable enough that somebody will pay
for it and if not then hustle as hard as
you can to improve your skills work with
some clients build up your abilities to
the point where you can start charging
[Music]
step number four is to start talking to
customers as soon as you can you want to
start talking to potential customers
this is one of the biggest mistakes and
entrepreneurs make they come up with an
idea they're really excited about it and
they just tinker and they tool and
they're by themselves and they're coming
up with all sorts of different crazy
ideas which is great and exciting but
you're never actually testing it against
the market right that example before I
said it's got to combine what you love
doing with what people are willing to
pay you for if you spend all your time
on here thinking you doing something
great and you never talk to the people
who are actually pay you to do the thing
that you want to do you're never gonna
build a business and too many
entrepreneurs spend so much time on that
thing on that idea of working by
themselves in their home in their
apartment in their condo in their
basement without ever actually testing
it and you can go down the wrong path I
made this mistake in my first business
you know I spent an entire summer
working on a business plan and thinking
what I thought would be amazing and I
came out like this is the best thing
ever and then we started talking to
customers and I realized that some of
what I thought was true was actually
true and some of it wasn't what they
cared about at all and if I just talked
to my customers or potential customers
first then I could build a better
solution for them instead of wasting an
entire summer working on that I could
have made a lot more progress so think
about who your ideal customers are who
you're going to be selling this product
or service to and as soon as possible
go start talking to them you may not
have a product or service to sell yet
that's okay say here's what I'm thinking
about doing tell me about your problems
right if they have a problem that's an
opportunity for you problems for other
people are opportunities for
entrepreneurs and so if you're talking
to customers and they have a big enough
pain point a big enough problem
that's when you know you have an
opportunity to go in and solve it so as
soon as possible in the process as
you're building your product or service
up start talking to people to get their
feedback and build it around them and
you
[Music]
tip number five is focused on service
focus focus focus focus on your customer
service this will be the most important
way to build your business especially at
the beginning don't worry about social
media
don't worry about posting all over the
place don't worry about taking out
advertisements you'll get distracted if
you have a limited amount of time every
single day to focus on your business
what you want to do is get as close to
your customers as possible and then
service their needs as best you can what
you want is your customers telling other
people about the great work that you do
and if your focus is spread across so
many different things as much as I love
social media as much as I love YouTube
if somebody's just getting started in
business I would not recommend going
all-in on social I'd be looking at how
do I get as close as possible to my
customers how do I provide them an
amazing service to the point where they
would want to tell somebody else about
me do that because you need
word-of-mouth as an entrepreneur you're
not gonna have the budget to go off and
buy huge commercials and take a big ad
spend you need people talking about you
and that comes from providing the best
possible service especially at the
beginning because you're still learning
how to do the thing that you're doing
you haven't provided the perfect product
or service yet and so understanding
where you're falling short understanding
how you can help them more people are
willing to be forgiving and
understanding if they feel like you
really care and so if you want people to
care about you then you gotta show it
first care about them help them in as
many ways as possible design the best
possible experience for them and try to
help them in ways beyond just what you
were hired to do you do that then you
stand out and they will tell their
friends and that kick-starts the
referral marketing for you
[Music]
step number six is make it your goal to
get to survival it's great to have an
amazing goal right we have a big vision
we want to change the world we want to
make lots of money you want to have a
huge impact we want to touch tons of
lives it's great you definitely need
that big-picture thinking and you need
to act small like your next step is to
just get to the point where you can
survive the goal for any part-time
business owner is to get to the point
where that part-time business is making
you enough money to survive so you can
spend more time with it if you are
making enough money part-time to be able
to survive pay your bills I'm not
talking about getting new cars it's as
paying the internet bills paying for
food right
like basics to survive if you can do
that while working part time then it
allow you to quit your job or however
else you're making money right now and
go full-time right you go full-time when
you're making enough money from your
part-time job to survive that should be
your first goal and then you keep going
right like yes my longer-term goal my
five-year plan or 10-year plan or
whatever it looks like is to have the
global impact and make a huge difference
I love it yes keep doing it what happens
a lot of times is entrepreneurs get
stuck in the dream world like the the
final vision of what they want to do and
then they don't take any immediate
action like they're waiting for a big
deal to happen they're waiting for the
venture capital funding to come in
they're waiting for the government to
change the laws they're waiting they're
waiting they're waiting they're wait and
then like nothing happens don't be that
person think big act small start getting
going right get your part-time business
to the point where you're making enough
money to survive that's your first goal
then you can quit your job and go all-in
on your company
and tip number seven is be consistent
and this ties back to the first rule
about scheduling it in you need to be
consistent people just give up too soon
so many entrepreneurs quit one because
they just picked the wrong thing they're
just chasing opportunity they're not
interested in it they don't love it
that's fine
but if you love it you can't quit on it
right because you're gonna look back on
your life when you're 80 90 100 200
years old and say like I should have I
could have done more I should have done
more I regret that that's a lifetime of
regret that's ahead of you if you don't
just give it your all and you don't be
consistent a lot of entrepreneurship is
just following through and everyday
doing one more thing and one more thing
and putting one foot in front of the
other if you look at the successful
careers of most entrepreneurs it's not
these giant leaps forward it looks like
an overnight success and some big huge
thing happened but to get there was a
lot of these tiny little steps that
people just took consistently a lot of
these tiny little steps that on their
own seemed like nothing but it led to
the next step and led to the next step
and led to the next step but doing that
on a daily basis you look back and say
wow I accomplished so much that month I
accomplished so much that week but each
individual day wasn't that much that's
the key not giving up every single day
taking some kind of small action to move
forward and if you allow that to happen
momentum starts to build people start to
talk and all of a sudden some huge
things start taking off for you but it's
as a result of being consistent every
single day 30 to 60 minutes no excuses
keep going keep driving be consistent
sticky so those are my seven suggestions
on how to get started part time I made
this video because Sad asked me to if
there's a topic you'd like me to cover
in a feature several ways video check
out the link in the description you can
go and cast your vote and hopefully I'll
make one for you coming up soon I love
to know what did you think of this video
which of the seven resonated the most
with you is here an 8 9 10 that you want
to add to the list let me know leaving
the comments below I look forward to
hearing what you have to say I also want
to give a quick shout out to Ray on my
team right thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word and
posting it to your Facebook account
I really really appreciate support I
love your one word of focus and thank
you for sharing as well thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you open
to believe in yourself and whatever
you're one where it is
much love I'll see you soon yeah the
most important work ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple so it
would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details